scripts are just awful when the writer
tells you everything did I say that mine
said that okay who she's not a
screenwriter she's not a producer she
has been in the business a long time as
a unit publicist and she she has
exquisite taste in films and I remember
asking her because I was asked that for
I think a topic of an article and I said
what would you say is one of the things
that makes has made you want to get
involved with a script and what do you
think makes the script really good and
if we came out of her mouth is what
makes scripts awful is when characters
tell you everything so examples are if a
husband and a wife let's say a wife saw
her husband having lunch with another
woman that she didn't know about and he
comes home from work he's like hi honey
how's your day and she were to say what
she'll probably say in real life is it
nothing with that kind of you know I
mean Matthew Waters a master of the
subtext I recommend looking at just
about any episode of Mad Men but much
less interesting so or she might say
that the husband comes in and says what
did you do today and I was in a similar
situation once with and I did not say I
saw you with another woman having lunch
today I wanted him to like I wanted to
maybe catch him in a lie
I said or actually like well I you know
what did she do today and he said
nothing special really did you have
lunch somewhere interesting what are you
talking about and like maybe one of the
things that I love is that if you really
play along with that you can also play
with the audience in terms of them
thinking oh yeah he was having an affair
then we find out that it was an in
your decorator and he was surprising his
wife by he just bought a little vacation
home and he was making sure that where
you just like was renting in Malibu a
place and he wanted to make sure all
this stuff was special for their
anniversary and then what can happen is
if she keeps testing him and testing him
and and she like starts bringing up old
stuff about how he pisses her off that
scene could end with him not telling her
what the surprise was and the couple
deciding you never trust me you know
what I was gonna do something nice with
for you and screw you I want a divorce
I'm just spinning here and I'm not
saying that that's you know they the
greatest scene but that's an example of
when you play with subtext versus
characters saying everything that
they're thinking another example if you
take streetcar named desire with Blanche
and Stanley and Stella and if you had
Blanche saying well I really have been
working as a prostitute and I'm
depressed and I have nowhere else to
live game over like not very interesting
so if you think about it in those terms
um yeah it's um and it's really
reflecting how people are in real life
people don't always say exactly what
they're thinking and feeling oh not at
all yeah but that's what makes it so
interesting too because you like you
said going along on the ride wondering
will there be a raised eyebrow that will
reveal something or exactly versus
because then it just has like this flat
tone and it really doesn't replicate you
in life and I feel like that's one of
the things that I was saying earlier
when you would ask what I love about
movies is that we can vicariously put
ourselves in the other characters
situation and we can say I've been in a
situation like that I didn't want to
confront my husband if he'd been with
another woman and so on and so forth so
or that like if you can tell sometimes
if there's like gossip or somebody said
something about you so they come in
how are you exactly yes and you know
they want something from a statement and
then we can I sour self in the the
feeling of the person who is suspecting
that maybe they were talking about her
but they're not coming out and saying
right so I think that's such a good
point that you bring up is that it
really engages us so much more and
because that's a comment that I said a
lot you want to be engaged I mean good
writing good script the scripts at
command attention is with an
extraordinary capacity to engage your
reader and that's usually through really
smart dialogue like that like what you
were talking about he talked about two
scripts that don't propel the character
forward mm-hmm so can we can we have
maybe some examples of ones that would
and then ones that don't or just some
themes all right well gosh okay Breaking
Bad is such a great example of an
escalation of situations and yeah so I
would say that's the character every
step that he takes there's a consequence
and it leads to another and another and
then the character am I try and get
himself out of it but it's it's it's
kind of like the notion of Macbeth once
you create or do something bad it is it
has its own momentum the I it's hard to
say without really doing specifics but
basically every scene you want to feel
that you're advancing the story you're
advancing the plot even if a character
has a setback that's there's still it
there's still one of the I guess best
ways to think about it is that there's
the core spine of the story where a
character primary character or you may
have an ensemble but that each has a
goal that there's a primary objective
that
character is trying to obtain and the
obstacles that get in the way that
prevent them from that and how they even
if it's a step back but then they're
still trying to overcome that obstacle
there are in most movies successful
movies follow that formula I hate to say
formula because I don't like to things
be being formulaic and an example really
where stories are not propelled forward
is when I think the writer loses focus
that the focus is to diffuse and one of
the common reasons for that would be
when there are too many characters when
a writer is introducing so many
characters that rather than get to know
one or a few really well we're getting
glimpses of all these different
characters but none of them because they
don't have time to develop them
particularly well and so we don't have a
core sense of what a character's primary
focus or a group of characters primary
focus and goal is what are the obstacles
that get in their way so I think anytime
there's a really diffuse focus and then
scripts don't they one of just being
very dispersed and rather than having a
through-line
you